[Music]
whip up a bug what up a 50 gamer person
here
Titus right wait wait hello I can hear
myself this is so annoying
in case you haven't realized this is a
game that uses my voice that's right
everybody one hand clapping one hand
that's how you do it in case anyone is
curious let's check out this game this
is so annoying I turn this off
hello Amahl hello
okay sing hum or whistle you're lower
than your lower zone
okay I'm walking hey hey why is it so
awkward to use my voice in the game
Chris escape at any time to recalibrate
okay sing or whistle to affect the world
5 met on YouTube in six months never
done before that was this damn bond them
haters that's it that's it
that's what I thought it's baby you're a
firework
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god Jesus Christ is anyone still
watching after that my god that was
beautiful thank you wow what a great
game you played Felix what a great idea
to play this game Jesus Christ
[Music]
you gotta assert dominance that's what
this is all about within your range you
don't know my range
[Music]
I gotta make rainbow I met every do that
[Applause]
spots eat oh hello everybody my name is
Jackson again and I love video games
that is what I do
very sharp bridge deck top of the
morning to you laddies my name is Jack
Spade I see playing I love to play video
get to why did I do that
hahaha
that'll never work
my name is Barry and I have a very small
everybody wants to see it but it's a big
secret
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like that Beyonce clip
[Applause]
[Music]
that is so cool what a brilliant game
I'm super impressed I just thought it
would be another like early version
garbage this is actually really cool
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
maybe it's better for people that can't
sing but you know I got it done
I got it working all right
yeah oh great ba-ba-ba-ba yeah heck yeah
guys were killing me
[Music]
I hear myself
Oh God is it that bad
Oh
let's listen to that again without the
backing track
[Music]
Oh
ray
I love it so awesome
here we are beautiful oh god it keeps
going
[Music]
easy-easy penis man you ain't got
nothing
oh he's following me now what is this
we're gonna sing together
[Music]
hell yeah that's what I'm talking about
that's what this is all about I just
want to fight a boss with like an epic
sing battle you know
wouldn't that be epic come on hide they
better
why are you shining on ham
[Music]
guys dare dare dare judge air
dude edited edited there dude it I get
it
you feel free to lick my butt because it
tastes like skittles
hey hey morning gay but they wanna gasps
oh my god
Wow one hand clapping that's how it's
done everybody what a great demo or game
I don't know either way I had a lot of
fun
hey guys watching let me like if you had
fun watching me screams and I'll see you
tomorrow with another video goodbye
[Music]